[Musique]
en tournant sur la tête en équilibre sur
les bras ou des tours de passe-passe la
culture hip hop mis à l'honneur par
l'association world step event de
maurepas en co organisant les
qualifications régionales de break dance
pour le championnat de france c'est de
promouvoir le hip hop auprès des jeunes
et auprès de tout public d'ailleurs
puisque le hip hop c'est une culture
c'est une philosophie et du coup en fait
c'est aussi de pouvoir créer une
compétition parce que effectivement la
danse c'est culturel mais c'est quand
même un sport
plusieurs catégories dans cette
compétition junior girl liboi top rock
et écrous chaque breaker à sa
préparation sa technique et son ressenti
musicale je mets chauds je fais quelques
mouvements mais pas trop non plus
pourquoi montrer aux autres
mouvementée après une fois qu'on est
lancé faux
retour données et
le but c'est d'être musical tout en
étant technique ça c'est assez difficile
à faire il faut savoir combiner les deux
je joue beaucoup sur l'énergie et
l'agilité et tout en essayant d'être
musicale beaucoup de
de passe-passe mélangés à des phases
voilà avec des bonds blocage sur la
musique
emprise engagé dans la catégorie bboy
cam il s'est arrêté en demi-finale
caelis viril lui a remporté le concours
top rock
il est qualifié donc pour les
championnats de france prévus à liévin
le 18 novembre prochain